[inaudible]
joining me today is a comedian,
a writer for the Daily News and the spectator,
the former sex columnist,
step playboy,
and a woman in the midst of taking off Twitter for lent.
Bridget.
Tracy,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
You are in the midst of taking off Twitter for land.
As I just said,
you were on a break from legal characters and attacking people and owning people
and destroying people and getting a deck.
I know exactly what she smiling about.
How's it going?
Before we get into anything else about you,
I mean,
how,
so first of all,
how long have you been doing it for?
A couple of weeks.
Okay.
Yeah,
so I inadvertently didn't know that this was the line just lent ever.
So it's normally 40 days,
but because of the way you serve falls edse 46 days.
Oh Man.
And um,
uh,
there's 26 days left.
Some 40 days at or sorry,
20 days in,
right.
Um,
of my 46,
which is why Twitter,
why giving up Twitter of all things.
So I have
not many vices left.
I've given up drinking.
I've given up smoking weed,
I've given up.
I mean,
if there's something that you can quit,
I'm pretty much quite at other than coffee and Twitter.
And I thought that I would give up coffee because that was the easiest of the
two.
And I tried to do that.
I want to kill myself.
And so I decided that I would give up Twitter and I'm,
I'm like you,
I take weekends off sometimes.
I try and I felt in February really addicted to it.
I remember there would be days where I'd say,
okay,
9:00 AM you're off.
You shouldn't even be doing it in the morning,
but by 9:00 AM get off and go do something.
And then it's 11 and I'm like,
well I'll just do until 11 yeah.
And then it's noon and then,
and this is very addictive thinking.
Oh well I've already ruined my whole half of my day.
So now just until the rest of the day I'm just going to tweet and I can feel
myself that refresh,
refresh,
like a little rat.
What was that like when you realized that the kick that you're go go,
go pick or whatever it is,
is sort of like some of the things that you've quit cause you've been,
you've been sober for about five years.
Yep.
Yup.
Yeah.
Five and a half,
a little bit.
Who's,
and the,
it wasn't necessarily noticing the kick,
it was noticing the inability to,
the lack of parallel feeling,
kind of powerless over being able to stop when I wanted to stop.
Yeah.
If I put an end time not being able to meet that end time having it,
I,
it's very much like my life started journaling a little bit unmanageable.
Yeah.
Things.
And even just seeing how much the most interesting thing that's come of the two
weeks or a little more then,
um,
I guess almost three weeks now is how much physical energy I have.
So how this,
and this I haven't really found the science on because I'm a nerd.
So I went down all these science halls and now I'm looking at reading this book
irresistible,
which is all about addiction and all the studies and it's brilliant.
But why do I,
how is something so passive,
taking so much energy,
actual physical energy.
So you physically feel better?
Oh,
physically I have so much actual energy.
And what is it?
Just because the adrenals,
you're getting kind of fired up when you have that adrenaline.
I don't know how you feel when you're on,
I generally step away if I start feeling reactive.
Yeah.
I,
if I'm,
if I started feeling my heart racing and even when I'm kind of addicted,
I'm like,
okay,
Bridgette.
Yeah.
What do you think of them way?
What about the mental clarity?
So that's been I,
the productivity is,
I've written,
I've been doing a daily writing prompt on my patrion.
I've read on just that alone.
I've done 15,000 words.
I wrote a 12 page book proposal.
I did,
I been keeping diary of a Twitter junkie.
I just,
the daily how I feel and whatnot.
And um,
that's another probably 20,000 words.
I,
I'm pretty much written a book.
I mean,
that's why you're doing it.
Right?
That's about the same amount that I probably would have written on Twitter.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Great.
Um,
so it's interesting because when I've done this and as you know,
I do the weekends and I do the August thing.
What I found is,
especially when it's not just the weekend when it's the longer one,
is that I'm just generally calmer.
Like I'm not bad neurotic or whatever in general.
But I find that like,
like my patience level,
like if I'm at the supermarket,
you know,
normally you're like checking out and you're maybe looking at your phone or
whatever,
where now it's like,
I'm more inclined to say hello to the person that's checking me out or just like
a little more presence.
I am so much more present.
Yeah,
definitely that,
that has been a remarkable difference and everything.
And even people in my family and my sister,
we were joking about the other day and she said,
Eh,
you are more present.
Even just on the phone with her and in my life.
And I feel like even my dog notices that it just,
that my dog's here are connected to me and I'm like,
is this because I'm just not on my phone all the time?
And it's the,
but I'm a maniac.
I have an addictive personality and I'm just a maniac in general.
And so the first week I would say I went through real withdrawal.
And it was interesting because I went to,
I went to mass on Ash Wednesday because I figured if I was going to do it,
I might as well it partake in my ritual.
I'm not some great Catholic,
but I went and I was feeling kind of ashamed that I was quitting something so
stupid as Twitter and the priest or the monsignor gets up and he's giving his
sermon and he says,
lent means slow in French and that,
I mean this is a time we're supposed to go with them and look at how we can help
those who are suffering and,
and he said,
we need to slow down.
And then he reaches under his Cassick and he pulls out his cell phone and holds
up in front of the whole parish and says,
and put these down.
Yeah.
And I looked around and I was like,
we have a problem.
Society when going to distances up [inaudible] he's holding up his cell phone in
front of the bearish telling you to put it down.
It's like destroying your relationships here and that was when I look over my
odd who's on her phone and the church is hilarious.
Yeah.
Well it's interesting because it's like we can't quite quantify how having
access to this much information so fast.
Just out of nowhere,
basically only within the last say 10 years.
We have just no idea how it's rewiring our brain the way we think,
the way we behave.
Yeah.
Each other there while they do all these studies on empathy with the younger
kids and how that's,
you need to have those,
one of the things about the world we live in,
even just cancel culture,
et Cetera,
I feel like there's this diminishment of being awkward.
You can't,
nobody is allowed to have these awkward interactions,
which is how you,
you might say something wrong and then somebody will have a look on their face
and you know,
oh,
I went,
I stepped over a line.
But because everybody's living in so much fear of saying the wrong thing or
they're there,
there isn't this like awkward or they're just on their phones where they can
have text messaging interactions and not hear tone and body language.
So there's this loss of of making mistakes and being awkward and even I'm s and
you see it all across the board right now.
Yeah.
So that,
that's been,
it has been interesting.
Just if you sit in a restaurant and you are,
say you and I went to eat and you went to the restroom and I just sat there and
did not look at my phone,
I would look like a psychopath every month.
God,
she's just sitting there looking at the wall.
Right.
And this and the vogue irresistible.
He says that there's an inability for us to just be bored.
That as humans we used to just have this idle time and I look at my screen time
and you know,
you'll see your screen report and it'll say something like,
oh,
your screen to irons down 45% you're like hurray.
And then it's like to fire him hours to speak to 27 hours.
What am I doing for five and the number of times you pick it up I we're rads or
elaborate.
Here's the catch 22 though that the internet and all this connectivity has also
given us,
I mean I can talk about just the two of us.
We live in the digital space and we've created things that people appreciate and
all of those things.
It's also given us everything that we want in a certain way.
Like I'm so appreciative of my life and it's through that connectivity.
I know,
but that doesn't mean that it's not a dangerous sword to wheel a bit I suppose.
And I would feel so isolated ideologically.
I do in twice,
like 2016 approaching 2016 being in La,
I started feeling like I was going crazy.
I truly,
yeah,
and it was you and people finding people like online and that's how I kind of
came out of the space of,
I would say we're just living in a,
on Twitter.
I was really just around comedians and writers and then slowly kind of drifted
into political Twitter,
which was always there.
Now you're full on.
All right,
now I'm on your zone.
I'm not saying hey.
Yeah,
so I'm,
I'm happy to be inducted into this club.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's,
let's go there for a second.
So one of the things that,
the reason that I've wanted to have you on for quite some time as I've sort of
been watching through Twitter,
your,
what I would say political awakening is because you strike me as just a sort of
old school lefty liberal,
whatever,
but you are seriously waking up to or have woken up to just the postmodern
thinking and left this nonsense and all of this stuff about free speech.
And we'll talk about me to in the piece you wrote and,
and a series of other things like it seems like every day I can see you getting
like a little more and a little bit more like we are baseball is anyone saying,
but this isn't the problem.
So I have,
I have to check myself and these are the questions like that I would have for
you.
For instance,
as somebody with what I thought were liberal values,
I,
I don't like how in this tribal world it's like the left gets social justice and
the right gets family values.
No,
those,
everybody should care about those things.
I know plenty of people on the right who care about social justice and plenty of
people on the left who care about family values.
How would you define social justice when you say that?
Um,
oh gosh.
I mean I think just caring about other people.
I feel like there's an idea that people on the right are callous and don't care
about
right.
They old one hour about move taxes,
Money in themself and essentially are,
there's a callousness I would think that is applied to that.
But I do think that people,
well,
I found that to be completely untrue,
but I that I've met these people,
I,
yeah,
I did think that years ago.
So my biggest thing that I have to check myself is am I reacting to rejection?
So in being somewhat rejected by the former party,
although I don't feel rejected,
I feel like I didn't move and just went,
yeah.
You know,
like they're drifting away.
Yeah.
And I,
I'm,
I kind of,
I explain it to people.
Like I was this customer of regular at a bar and I was a regular at the bar and
then they took me as a voter for instance.
And they,
yeah.
And I just kind of went to that bar all the time.
They knew me.
I grew up going to that bar with my grandpa and my dad and it was it a family
bar tradition.
And then suddenly they stopped caring about me and they started caring about the
hipsters are the beards and craft beers and stuff and they stopped caring about
just their regular customers and the normal common sense folk and started making
these fancy drinks.
I like this metaphor.
They somehow lost me as a customer because now I am a registered independent and
you'll see the criticism of on the left,
I see this a lot of,
well,
um,
somebody said something I didn't like and so I stopped believing in and you
know,
equality and women's rights and I abandoned all of my principals and became a
conservative and
I don't,
I don't think that's a fair assessment.
That assessment I think has no self reflection,
which is my biggest I,
that's really,
people accused me too.
They say,
Oh,
you don't call out the right enough.
Well,
I'm not a conservative.
Yeah.
I don't know any,
I'm learning about conservatism,
but I didn't know anything.
I didn't,
I wasn't raised,
I was raised a blue blood,
Yankee,
Democrat,
liberal.
My parents saying for the camp,
my dad sang for the Kennedy is like [inaudible] that was where I came from.
Yeah.
And so coming,
I just wasn't really paying attention and then suddenly I felt like that what's
happening?
How are these,
how,
how is it that they're,
you know,
it's suddenly like punk rock to be conservative.
All right.
I want to back up to this bar metaphor.
I like what you're doing here.
So,
okay,
hipsters come in,
they've got their fancy drinks,
you know,
you're,
you don't know where you are anymore.
The Bio that you and your dad and your grandpa were and where do you go?
So you walk out of the bar.
What happens now I'm welcomed with open arms by the outright.
What are you shocked when you go into the other bar next door that you thought
was the evil bar and you realize that,
Whoa,
there's some decent people in this,
in this crazy conservative at world.
People are,
well,
I'm always like,
are you,
I'm moved every year and a half growing up.
So I am very sensitive to mob mentality in general.
I'm very aware of groups and how they like to form and tribes and I've always
been the girl on the outside kind of looking at,
and so this space that I'm occupying now is not really that unfamiliar to me.
But what was shocking was finding that they weren't evil.
These like evil people and that their values,
you know,
we can have differences.
And of opinion.
And that seems to be the thing that concerns me the most is that there doesn't
seem to be any tolerance for different differing opinions or nuance,
which is what's worrisome.
And so the new bar seems to be a little bit more tolerant.
However,
I'm also aware that they're more than happy.
Happily,
they will more than happily weaponized.
Somebody like me as like the disaffected liberal who no longer,
you know,
who is rejected from her tribe.
It's not.
Yeah.
Right.
So isn't that true?
So how do they weaponize that?
Cause that people will say that to me.
We'll see you left the left and now the rights embracing you because they just,
they want to use you to show that,
that you're not that bad or that they're not that bad or something like that.
Like,
well there they don't seem to be that bad.
Right?
No,
it's true.
But what I mean by weaponizes that they will happily abandon me if I don't.
It's not like they're taking me on as one of them,
so they're not taking me in to their tribe for it to protect me.
And the minute that I express any nuance for anything that may not be in
alignment with them there,
there will be no defense of me.
I'm pretty,
I bet.
I bet that will change.
I bet you think that will change.
Yeah.
Because I go to all these conservative turning point college events and I talk
about being pro choice and gay married and pro weed and for strong prison reform
and against the death penalty,
all these lefty things and they keep inviting me back.
They love the differences that,
I mean that's really what I'm finding.
But I hear you like that.
It's weird.
It's weird to think that's possible when you're in that new bar.
Yeah,
but that's just what I've found.
I,
I've found they're more open minded and I can have these discussions with openly
about things that I didn't feel like there again,
there was not room for discussion and there have been just the,
the most
my awakening really came when I started noticing that I was self censoring.
So I just started recognizing that I was not speaking freely.
And even when I went in to Michael knolls show,
I remember we were all just in makeup and talking and I was like,
oh,
it's so nice to be able to just speak freely and not be walking on eggshells and
afraid that I'm going to use the wrong term or what wrong.
Anything.
And just that recognizing that that was happening was something that pushed,
you know,
I would say it was s where not only was I ignored at the bar,
but suddenly I was not sure I wanted to be in that bar anymore.
Yeah.
Because I felt like I wasn't really welcome and part of me.
Is it,
am I just old?
You know,
it's just progress and maybe I'm like the old lady that's like,
this doesn't the way,
Dang,
you like art.
I seriously hope that pick,
I'm only two years older than you.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean there,
there is a certain amount of stuff that I've learned from younger women where
they've there the whole stuff of consent culture for example.
I,
I think that again,
it's,
it's eroding a lot of awkwardness and the like,
can I touch your hair?
Yeah.
It's kind of,
and just human sexuality trying to put that much control on it is crazy to me.
However they,
the younger women are like,
just cause you all bags put up with leg,
somebody smacking your ass while your waitressing doesn't mean that we have to
and that.
Okay,
fair enough.
But that's different than,
than concern culture,
right?
Yeah.
I think most,
most decent people,
I think probably most of those scary conservatives in that bar.
Yeah.
Probably nuts in the lap in the waitresses acid,
that bar actually,
you know what,
they're secretly doing it in the first bar you were at the same time,
they're pretending that they,
they're all about women and all that.
All girls.
The board though.
I mean I've experienced that.
Yeah,
that's bad.
I would say.
Yeah,
it's,
I think my point was really that I just probably turn my head to a certain
amount of sexual harassment like that the younger generation just doesn't
accept,
which is not a bad thing.
So where do you,
how do you,
you've,
you've written about this a little bit,
how do you draw the lines on all of that?
What you're describing is just sort of basic human emotion with each other and
that we need a certain amount of freedom and ability to make mistakes and
pushing each other and that we have certain desires and that,
you know,
but they can't be just like unbridled desires and all of that with a culture.
Now where are the,
you know,
they want you to sign documents before you have that black people and there's
apps where you both have to consent,
we're going to do this,
this,
this and this
sign can be withdrawn retro actively.
I think you can still look back and say,
oh no,
I didn't choose it.
What is the point of getting signed to take it back?
There's that ridiculous story from like a year ago,
I forget what school it was.
We're both students,
the male,
the female after accused each other of rape,
they both accused each other because they wanted to get the leg up on the other
one quick.
Like,
that's how,
so how do you,
how do you manage,
I mean if someone that writes about texts and all this stuff,
how do you,
how do you negotiate?
I mean this was part of the reason that I,
I think again,
when you want to talk about my awakening,
I was the girl that was writing from playboy,
like it was still the 90th because I would,
I didn't go to college and so I didn't have the indoctrination of a lot of this
woke culture.
I'm not woke at all.
And I would say things like,
and my first article,
um,
it was,
uh,
women date assholes because you're a pussy
and it did not go over well with the left or the right.
That was the first time that I was just like mutually getting,
yeah.
So what was the,
hey,
you were getting from me.
The men's rights activists and stuff were saying like,
the men don't generally like being called Pussy is if you,
if you can't,
if,
I mean essentially they're like,
oh,
so if I can't get laid,
I'm a pussy,
you know,
like that you screw you.
And then that it was like toxic masculinity on the law on from the like extreme
feminists.
And that happened to me a lot.
They extreme men and women often,
I don't think they realize how close and the circle they are.
What do you make of that whole situation right now that it seems like at some
level we're entering like this low grade war of the sexist.
Like this sounds like a bizarre dystopian story.
No,
I know.
And it's,
I don't think that,
so I don't think you need to emasculate men in order to empower women.
And I feel like this is kind of the,
there's so many double,
it's like,
okay,
so you're talking to me about toxic masculinity and you're saying toxic
masculinity this and men can't show their emotions.
Oh,
but sit the sit down and shut out.
Actually,
we don't want to hear from you at all guys,
unless you are,
uh,
a trans man or unless you are a person of color who's gay or if you check some
boxes,
we,
you're allowed to speak.
But other than that,
if you're a white male,
like shut up.
Well,
where does that fall into your toxic masculinity and how is that helpful?
Because from my experience writing for men and hearing from men,
um,
CIS Hetero men,
the red blooded male,
the Alpha male and my kind of dude,
um,
they are struggling.
You know,
they,
they're,
I,
I would,
I did some,
some of my favorite pieces or pieces like on balding or,
um,
premature ejaculation and men,
I'd say,
hey guys,
what do you think about this?
And it would be essays,
thousands of words.
No one's really asking them questions,
how they're doing.
And when you do ask them,
hey,
how are you doing?
It's like a fountain of pain essentially.
It's so fascinating to me because as you know,
I've been on tour with Jordan Peterson.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And it's like,
people always say it's angry young men coming to his shows in,
first of all,
I don't find them to be angry,
but they are people that are trying to put their lives together.
But I always think it's such an odd criticism because let's pretend it was 90%
angry white,
cisgendered toxic men and he was helping them deal with some of their issues.
That would be a good thing.
Right?
So the blanket accusation of,
Oh,
you know,
you're just writing for straight white men or that it's mostly straight white
men that show up to these things.
And I'm not even saying that's the case.
It's,
it's such a low level argument because everyone needs help regardless of their
gender or their skin.
A skin color.
Yeah.
And people are,
you know,
women haven't given,
I feel more tools and they just are allowed to express themselves emotionally
and society and men really aren't.
And so it,
they don't have tools,
they just don't have as many and they don't feel as comfortable opening up.
I don't feel like men particularly feel comfortable opening up even to other
men,
although they might be getting better at that.
But it does seem like they'll open up to me because they feel comfortable.
I also did,
I just don't really judge anyone for whatever they come to me with.
And I'm certainly not judging someone by the color of their skin or by whatever
their politics might be because I feel like first we have to meet as humans and
I feel like we're all just on this same kind of sinking ship together and you
know,
it's like fighting over the last seat on the titanic.
Like why,
why are we,
what is,
how is this helpful?
I don't see that discourse right now being helpful and I don't see how you
basically taking an entire group of people and saying sit down and shut up.
Is is helpful.
I it how are is pressing a whole nother group of people?
Yeah.
How is it doing the same thing that you was done to you?
How does that help?
How,
how?
I was having a lunch meeting with somebody just about some business stuff and,
but he didn't actually know that much about my politics.
Right.
Other than what I do.
And we had this really good meeting and then at the end,
something about politics directly came up and he started saying this thing about
how it should be all women,
we should give to get rid of all men in politics than it should be all women and
blah blah blah,
and we have to topple the patriarchy and everywhere.
And I thought,
hey,
you're talking about [inaudible] he was a white man.
I mean,
so you're talking about taking yourself down [inaudible] he was also struck me
as very successful.
Probably a million other like you're,
you're like want to take all that down,
but also what are you actually saying?
So it's not inherent that if you just had all women doing things that things
would be better.
But that seems to be the weird place that we're in.
I wouldn't,
I don't think things would be better if we only had men doing it either.
No.
And again like you to go back to your point about the war of the sexes w we are,
which is also a weird thing to just because of all of the gender stuff too,
it's like this weird war of the sexes.
It's occurring under the s the idea that gender is a social construct.
I'm like right,
makes sense.
I feel like I'm losing my mind and I think a lot of people do.
Just normal people.
I mean I really,
I did a piece or I'm doing working on a piece.
Then I asked people that email me like how are you being self son?
How are you self censoring what's happening?
So when he did this on Twitter?
Yeah,
yeah.
And got immediately everyone was like,
don't write this piece.
And okay now just started getting attacked by blue check.
Verify journalists write this.
Yeah.
Journalists telling other journalists not to write a piece.
It's crazy.
But it's like,
it's like comedians policing other comedians for jokes.
This is another thing that I'm like,
are you kidding me guys?
When,
when did you become like,
I remember when everybody on the right was getting mad about rap music.
Like how is this the,
how are you the new literally have literacy comics calling for books not to be
Po.
I mean it's,
it's not.
So I,
and a lot of these mommies are getting shamed out of mommy groups because
they're not playing by the,
the gender thing or they don't understand it or they're just trying,
people are just trying to catch up and change in like one year.
Yeah.
And so one woman was writing me that,
um,
she went to get a birthday present and she walked into this store.
She lives in a liberal,
you know,
I think she's on the east coast in New York somewhere.
And she said,
Oh,
I can you wrap this for a girl?
And the woman,
she said,
you would have that I asked for.
And the woman was like,
we don't do that here.
Excuse me.
We have brown,
we have white,
we have gray,
we don't wrap for a gender.
And she was rude to her about it and like said a white,
you know,
she didn't know.
And this is turning,
and I think this is why I scream to the,
to the left the most,
is that they don't understand that they're pushing people away.
How much weight do you think is just that they,
they have this thing where it's like if you don't accept what they accept as
true,
the second they accept it,
you're the bad guy.
So if you don't come around to exactly how they are on trans issues right then,
you know what I mean?
Even if you're respectful of trans people and you're really trying to understand
these issues and understand gender and sexuality and these things,
but if you don't do it the second they do it,
if you don't come around to gay marriage the second they do it,
you know,
let's not forget Barack Obama was not for gay marriage the first time he ran.
History will not be too kind to him by these people's estimation.
It's that I don't,
most people don't even know.
They're just there and they kind of stumble into these,
into these inadvertent,
my friend for example,
who did my makeup,
she said,
um,
my kids are coming home with fully formed opinions about Trump.
They're eight and 11 that she's not giving them.
She said,
so where are they getting these opinions?
I had a family member who
are freaking out about that.
I mean,
she just,
she says,
you know,
everybody,
they have conversations about it in her home.
She did make up for somebody.
She posted a picture of
herself and ankle.
They're just like,
hey,
look who I did again,
stumbled into,
and she said she got completely eviscerated on Facebook and didn't even see it
coming.
So I think a lot of people have when they see this,
you know,
these kill shots that they,
they always go,
everybody swarms and other people observe this and the,
the public shaming and then it silences them.
So every time these little,
and we don't know how many of these little micro shamings are occurring all
across America.
And what worries me,
well,
not worries me,
but what's interesting to me is how many people there are like me who have,
and you know,
people are coming from the right as well for their own reasons.
Um,
and now they're,
you know,
independence.
They're basically like,
well,
I,
I'm,
there's crazy stuff on both sides and I believe in common sense and reason and
nuance and free speech and the,
you know,
scientific method and radical.
It's radical.
I had a dream last night actually.
I was,
I think I was nervous and I had a dream that I was on the show and I said,
I'm coming in hot Dave.
I haven't been on Twitter.
And it is liberating because I don't have to hear anything.
And I can say anything like,
boys and girls are different and you'll dream were like,
don't say that.
You're welcome to say it.
In reality with the beauty of this is,
so when we post this episode,
God only knows what you've said already,
that one of the Fed the masses and you won't even know for weeks,
but your cousin,
uh,
what's her name,
your cousin man is running your Twitter account now and sharing some stuff and
all that.
So do you think there's any chance that some kind of new center can develop
here?
I think there,
I'm optimists.
I Rhett run optimistic.
I generally think that,
um,
I hope I saw,
I saw Claire's interview and you know,
she was saying we have to share the risk and I love that idea.
Yes,
I love that idea of sharing the rest of that.
But I also have nothing to lose.
I don't have children in school who will be punished by my politics,
by their teachers.
I mean,
one of my family members during the election,
she had you tell her kids or teachers were insane because of this stuff.
They were coming home and telling her and they were crying and you know,
these are adults who are supposed to be teaching children.
And then she just said,
I had to tell him like,
your,
your are,
your teachers are insane,
right?
You're basically sending your kids to a mental institution all day long and then
you bring it home where you go whack out.
Why did you come up with today?
Yeah.
And then,
so I don't have,
and I'm not working in a corporation where I have a job that I could lose.
I don't deal with Hr.
Thank God.
Because that sounds like a nightmare.
Well,
you don't have nothing to lose because you've got writing gigs and you've got,
well,
either way for yourself.
I mean the,
the mob can come for anybody,
right?
Like it.
So it's not nothing
but people,
I guess I'll probably never know.
Somebody like me will never know what I've lost.
So for Ensigns,
I don't know what doors have shot.
I know that my politics on Twitter,
we'll keep me out of writers' rooms for,
for sure.
Yeah.
And I know,
and I actually know that for a fact that even somebody looking for someone who
is somewhat Sentras thought that I was too far.
Right.
Which is
right.
Well,
that's what they do to everybody.
Crazy.
That's the,
I mean,
it's,
so,
I know,
I don't know that some show runner won't see my Twitter and say,
no,
forget that girl.
She's a Nazi.
Um,
I,
I do know that I had a really brilliant editor,
Joe Don Italia.
He was my first editor of playboy and you said,
die on your own sword.
And I love that because that really is all that I can do and all that we can do.
And the great thing about the Twitter hiatus has been really being able to step
back and look at the big picture and perspective and the bigger themes that keep
coming up within these little mini micro outrageous and new cycles that we get
all do you stop by?
And one of those is free speech.
I will die on that hill.
That is a hell I will die on.
I'll be right there with,
yeah,
I will die on that hill.
And I,
and that was the biggest thing that I saw.
Um,
you know,
I have art Tavana,
he has amazing profiles with people.
Nobody will publish because they're just considered toxic.
Yeah.
One that was a great writer.
He,
we were talking about him right before he wrote it and he happened to write a
really nice piece about me and playboy where he,
where he was also critical of me and yeah,
but it was,
but he's an actual journalist and I thought,
yeah,
it took a lot for me to be willing to let him spend a day with me because I had
been thrown under the bus by these guys who have been in my home many times.
But like I watched him for a while and I was like,
he seems decent enough.
He is just,
he was on my Pi doubts and he's great and he's been checking in with me during
this Twitter hate us and said,
I was essentially bananas,
but art was the one who I was,
we were talking about this,
you know,
do I have anything to lose?
And I said,
well,
I,
the hard thing for me being off Twitter is that I really can trace every single
dollar that I make through Twitter,
whether it's through an editor who found me.
That's how playboy originally found me.
That's how I mow most of my patrons come through.
Um,
Twitter and he said,
Roy,
you're just a jar drug addict then started cooking meth in your base.
Yeah.
Oh No.
But I do,
I wouldn't have met art.
And so there is this,
again,
I'm optimistic.
I think that we,
there's this double edge sword of like w we are connected and we have,
are the conversations that are happening on podcasts that you have that Joe
Rogan's having.
I know you guys are,
I'll,
I'll paying the price for it and I cannot tell you how many men have told me
Jordan Peterson literally saved their life.
Whatever they want to think about him.
He's helping people in a really tangible way.
And that is,
that is opt bads.
That is hopeful for me.
However,
when I see that there are less and less outlets for this,
that the gatekeepers seem to be,
um,
you know,
shutting down like no conservative columnists if you're a leftist publication.
The stuff I've seen in terms of d platforming on Patriana,
I mean I shed lots of people.
You've got that at Tido.
We heard all our friends.
I've had a lot of my cause but some of my friends are still out there and and
Brown Calamari yardies on there is there and there's a big hat and it's like I,
in that regard I kind of feel bad because we,
cause Jordan,
Sam and I are leaving did cause like this or like little guys like me.
It's like I can totally see you my friend.
There's some things coming.
I mean there's at least two things coming.
I hope so because big and hopefully of these bro.
Yeah,
there,
that's what worries me is that I do,
I do believe that being able to have hard conversations talk about things.
Here are those things that you don't want to hear but be able to listen to them
know who is saying those things.
I want to know.
I don't want them to have to go underground and start groups and you know,
whatever they need to do.
Yeah,
go have your crazy youtube channel.
But then again,
I question the,
you know,
the,
what recently happened in New Zealand,
the these things that would generally be contained to small little groups in
like basement somewhere now do have a platform to kind of spread these ideas
quickly.
Well,
was so interesting because the,
in the manifesto,
he's basically saying he wants to start this war,
right?
And then what does everyone do on both sides?
They just start handing it to them and blade people,
blaming this person,
maybe this person and blaming this person and everyone calling each other Nazis.
And it's like you guys literally,
you're,
you're outsourcing your brains to people that are truly,
truly dangerous.
Yeah.
You're saying to anyone that's out there do something crazy,
right?
Something crazy and we're all going to pay attention to it.
It's like,
it's like me.
Worst really is the worst possible thing you can do.
Right.
And itself,
there's a lot of what I worried about,
I wrote this piece for playboy actually.
They'll,
they'll have me write it and it was,
um,
Donald Trump is already making America great again and I put it out on an
inauguration.
It was probably a little too soon for people to hear the message.
But essentially it was looking at the silver lining and I sat in,
I worry about the self fulfilling prophecy that every,
you know,
there's a great quote and that show deadwood and he,
the doctor says,
um,
I've seen more harm done with a man trying to justify their selves in a man
seeking to do harm and this is what worries me and what I see where it's like
you would rather have him be in collusion with Russia.
You would rather have him like be an ad,
a Nazi or whatever so that you can be right.
Yeah.
Like that's dangerous
cause and effect.
You're saying you'd rather us be in world war three,
right,
because Ruth is if he
so that you can be right.
Yeah.
Like guys,
some of these things are good that they're not true,
but that's that and you know,
I,
again,
I'm very much about doing work on yourself and keeping yourself in check and
that is something I constantly have to keep.
Even with like the Jessie's mom thing,
it's always all lying.
I was like,
something ain't right about this.
But the media goes all in on it.
The candidates,
the democratic hands,
all said,
what evidence of our evil,
racist country this is.
I'm sure some of them haven't even deleted the tweet.
Yeah.
Split.
Then today's news.
Yeah.
And it's basically everything dropped.
But as you went,
we're,
we're holding this for a couple of days.
So it was a few days ago that,
that the,
that the charges against him were all dropped.
Right?
It's like what,
how were these charges dropped?
There's the guys,
there's the video of the guys picking up the news.
But I had to check myself during that process to make sure that I wasn't just
excited that I wasn't so excited to be right.
That I wasn't overlooking the fact that maybe he was actually this thing that
actually happened.
I still don't think thank you dad.
Yeah.
But and through that whole process,
you know,
I think it's,
this is where I think each individual,
and it falls on us to do our due diligence on not just the news and our sources
of news,
but on ourselves.
And how much are we hoping for something so that we can be right.
That's something I think we all have to,
especially I would say to my friends on the left,
really look at that like,
yeah,
it's,
it's good that even when it came out that he may be faked a crime against
themselves and I,
it's good that these guys aren't walking around Chicago beating people.
That's a good thing.
But in a weird way,
they need to be a Russian,
a Russian,
the narrative they meet right.
For their narrative.
They need the Jesse smell,
that thing to be real,
to prove that America's racist in these things consistently proved not to be
real.
But let's shift a little bit too,
because,
uh,
you,
you write all sorts of things.
Am I okay?
My usually dive into the topics that are the most controversial that'll get you
off Twitter pretty quick.
You just wrote this piece about,
uh,
you don't have to go to college,
basically.
Stop wasting your money.
Stop wasting your money on.
No,
I don't think that was very popular.
Yeah,
you did that in the spectator pretty recently.
Yeah.
And the idea was that there are ways to get jobs in the future trade schools and
all sorts of other things that maybe you don't need this brainwashing experience
for four years in the past.
Yeah,
I was speaking with Carol Roth and she's brilliant and very into finance and you
know she mates,
we were talking about this and she said just the idea that it's like the return
on investment for six figures for a five figure return on investment just
doesn't make sense.
And I can only speak from personal experience and I for some people,
college is what you need to do if you're going to specialize.
I,
my argument is that the automatic just go to college mentality and then getting
out with this enormous amount of debt so that you can figure out what you want
to do.
That's an expensive way to figure out why you want to do,
and I realized this pretty quickly into my first year of college.
My,
I would go after my first semester,
I saw my loans and the debt that I was already in after one semester.
And I always wanted to be a writer and I was like,
well I know how to write so I don't need to spend four years doing this and then
get out and have that and then have to take jobs that I hate taking and be
miserable so that I can pay off my debt.
Or when I was working up on a goat farm in northern California,
there was a girl who has the quotes around code by Green go green guy.
Um,
it was like this long term job.
I told my family I was working on,
I go farm and they've,
you know,
like a humble county.
Yeah.
And there was a lot of people there who basically they,
it was not in their benefit to go into the workforce above,
you know,
they were working under the table obviously because then it didn't trigger their
student loans.
This is so there's like the deferment and I'm like,
what?
You're an engineer,
why are you,
why are you sitting here with me?
And I think that there are a million ways to skin a cat.
You know,
you,
we need trade workers,
we need,
um,
just so many different laborers and I've gotten a lot of criticism for this
article and a lot of it is fair.
Um,
so what is it also that we just don't need certain things that people are being
taught?
It's not only that we need people that have certain skills,
like physical skills,
but it's also that a lot of the stuff that people are majoring in college,
if you're majoring in,
you know,
feminist dance or lesbian band,
I,
I mean,
you know,
any of these things,
it's like,
okay,
well what do you think you just paid for for all of those years?
Yeah.
And I think I sat in my views like you're,
if you go get a degree in gender studies,
you're really only good for writing blogs on the Internet.
Yeah,
that's,
that's that.
What else are you going to do with that?
Maybe your teach,
but what really,
what
leads gender studies.
That's what you do.
What do you do though?
I mean,
what do you do with that degree?
So be practical about the,
I'm,
I generally,
because I have had to pay for it.
I didn't have,
if you are,
if someone's paying for houses or whatever,
go go to college,
get a degree.
There's a lot,
the pushback I've,
I've received that has been the most powerful is that statistically people die
sooner if they don't go to college.
Now I would think,
I think this probably has a lot to do with socio economic factors that are not
necessarily being taken into consideration as Asian correlation.
Right.
But the,
yeah,
exactly.
But I everybody went to college.
So it's also a study that you're like,
well,
there's an entire generation of people that went to college or what about a
generation of people who may be when became trade workers and maybe they went
and uh,
whatever Lord taught themselves how to Code Online,
which is what my,
another family member of mine dead.
There's so many.
It also sounds like a new version of like of like servitude to the likewhen when
Bernie gets out there and he's like free college for everyone,
which we know of course no is not free.
And then he says a guarantee of a federal job.
That sounds horrible.
So if we're going to four,
I mean in effect you're going to force everyone to go to college because the few
people who won't want it will be shamed into doing it and wasting their time
when they probably have all sorts of other skills and can do,
all right,
I'll go to school.
They can learn how to do coding or whatever else learned to code.
I don't know if I'm even allowed to say [inaudible] going to go the of guys
they're done,
but like,
and then the guarantee is that you'll get a federal job.
That sounds cool.
So you can work,
you can be a pencil pusher for the government with no real chance of ever
growing,
but you know,
never be fired.
So you just stay there forever and just suck money off other people.
That sounds terrible.
I'm not a genius by any means,
but I know I don't,
I don't want no one to work for the government.
I don't want them to have much of my money to do things where they just don't
seem to be that effect of every government institution I've had to deal with.
Yeah,
well you got to love it.
The lefties,
Trump is Hitler.
There were the government's evil,
the patriarchy,
patriarchy.
What's their answered more money,
give them more money.
I had,
I got into it with a friend about this the other night and I felt bad because we
hadn't talked in a while and I didn't realize that he,
he was,
um
hmm.
As fully
indoctrinated in the approved message as he was.
And I really just tend to ask questions and it's amazing how angry he was
getting at my questions.
He said,
you know,
I'm tired of all these white supremacists talking.
They can all just shut up.
And I said,
okay,
but why do you want to take her?
Like why do you want to give away your guns and cause then he went off on a
tangent about that.
And that I'm like,
I just want to know the logic.
That's it.
And he just
did it ever gets to a logical point because I,
I've had these conversations with friends and now sometimes former.
Yeah,
yeah.
It might be a farmer friend.
Do you ever find that like there's,
they always move the goalpost,
they always change the definition of words or they change how history is like,
do you ever find in one of those conversations you can get it to something that
has some shape?
We had,
you know how the conversation started because I made the mistake of telling him
that I was doing the Glenn Beck Radio show and I didn't even think twice about
it because I'm used to,
now I occupy a space that's a little bit more centrist and so I got,
I got,
I got lazy then his Fred felling,
yeah,
I just want,
the governor never got up and I got,
I was laughing so I was talking to him and he just like lost it on me.
I was like,
you're going on the,
and I said,
I will have this conversation with anyone who's willing to have a conversation
with me about that.
What was his implication at Glenn Beck is a white supremacist.
Well yeah,
obviously anyone now that that the whole idea,
and this is why I'm not sure how we escaped from the spine area and I was
writing about this yesterday and my journal,
they can't run on Twitter anymore and um,
may at the end of this,
if you want me to tweet out something very powerful for you,
screenshots of my journal.
Yeah.
Um,
Billy's out,
no,
I was writing about how,
because I'm making sure,
I always try to make sure that I keep myself abreast of the,
of whatever is being written on the left as well.
And
Aye,
I'm not sure how you escaped the binary of essentially the Republican Party is
the party of white supremacy and if you are conservative or Republican,
you are basically doing everything to uphold white supremacy.
And they're not saying that's true.
You're just saying,
that's I'm saying this is,
yeah,
this seems to be what the messaging is.
That as,
as I understand it,
I could be wrong,
but this seems to be what I'm reading and,
and uh,
what I,
what I'm hearing,
and I don't know how you escaped that binary.
Well,
think you relentlessly,
you have to call these people out,
right?
I mean,
that,
that's all you can do.
It's just not the case.
It's just not true.
But they own so much of the media and so much,
right?
It's academia at everything else that these messages keep coming through.
And now you've got a friend of yours probably telling you you're a white
supremacy.
[inaudible] Glenn Beck.
I,
I was,
I was a white supremacist for doing Ben Shapiro's election special.
I mean,
that was,
he
white supremacists likes more than an orthodontist.
I'm fairly,
apparently you can,
that,
that can be the case.
And so that,
that's,
um,
I recently,
I mean,
I stepped into,
I stepped into it and it was my own fault.
I hadn't had coffee and I was tweeting recklessly and I,
um,
I said something,
I came in defense of that white kid that was on the Gq cover and I was,
and I said,
like the war on white men and I meant to put quotes on it because yeah.
And I didn't know coffee and this is not an excuse that it was like early and I
was like,
oh,
there's not enough space,
we'll get possibly go wrong and not thinking.
And I got,
it was like two days of your garbage,
essentially your garbage.
I got called the grand wizard and it is weird when you're,
you know,
being called racist used to be like the worst yeah.
In salts.
And I grew up learning that that was a horrible and salt and so to have that and
somebody kind of stepped James Lindsey,
I actually stepped in and he was like,
Bridget,
I see what's happening here.
You are up against,
you know,
like critical theory and you need to just like log out and say nothing because
it will all be used as proof that you are a racist essentially.
Yeah.
And it was,
you know,
there's parts of it that were upsetting obviously,
and then parts of it that I was like,
this is not,
why are you calling me garbage?
Would you say that to my face?
Yeah.
Well there are anonymous and they're on Twitter.
Yeah,
they're not.
These were blue checks like they weren't,
oh it was,
it was a,
yeah,
it was a
w.
What do you make,
let's just back up to this point that the eye,
cause I saw this happen to you on Twitter,
that there were journalists actually trying to stop you from writing a piece.
What,
where do you,
what do you think about just the state of journalism?
Because to me,
to me at the moment,
especially after the last,
you know,
little time with the Mueller investigation or anything like it's over.
It really like CNN and MSNBC,
whatever shred of remote credibility they have left,
they've destroyed the New York Times is basically destroyed itself.
I don't say any of that with pleasure.
People think I'm saying it like,
Ha,
I'm not.
I,
if,
if those guys could just be a little bit better,
what they can self reflect,
self reflect or just instead of doubling down every time,
like now,
now they're all trying to throw Mueller under the bus cause he didn't do exactly
what they wanted and now we've got to instigate,
investigate him and just more government everywhere.
And it's like,
what are you guys chasing you chasing your own shadow,
right.
It's the state of journalism is,
is very worrisome to me because it,
and I do sometimes wonder about journalists on Twitter because you need it in
one respect.
But on the other respect,
you see everyone's politics.
So how could anything that you,
they row being unbiased,
you know,
where everyone's coming from.
And I do wonder,
did,
do you know Matt,
um,
how do you say his last name t to be Eba kb.
He wrote a piece,
a couple of them
thing.
Yeah.
About,
yeah.
And just had the state of journalism and he's been doing some really great
reporting,
actual journalistic reporting,
and he listed all of the links to every single thing that all of these
organizations,
CNN and the New York Times of sad and he compares it to the WMD.
Um,
you know,
he,
I think he,
there are still journalists who are critical of their fellow journalists.
And the criticism that came to me when I reached out for self censorship was
like,
oh,
here comes Bridgette writing another piece about how Trump supporters are self
censored.
No,
actually quite the contrary.
That's not what I'm looking for.
I'm,
I'm wondering how liberals ourselves censoring and they don't want to hear it.
Generally somebody said,
you know,
and you get the most flack when you're over the target.
Yeah.
And I definitely just,
the fact that everyone piled on,
they don't,
they do not want to hear how they might be pushing their own party away.
People in their party.
And these are the people that they need.
There's no more votes to the left to the far left.
You've gone as far left as you can go.
Boys.
And girls aren't different anymore.
We can't go anywhere
for the last,
well that's why they want to lower the voting age to 16 though know.
I mean really that's it.
But the lower the voting age change electorial college ads,
members of the Supreme Court.
I mean these are all ideas that are being floated by them right now because yes,
there's no that that intersectional competing interest,
cacophony can't hold forever.
You run out of people destroyed,
come back a little bit and be somewhat reasonable.
If only somebody had been talking about this for these last five years.
Yeah.
What do you feel?
Do you feel like people are from the left or are kind of waking up as well or do
you feel like they're just as the cognitive desinence just like I need to just,
I would double down.
Yeah,
the core of the left where the energy of the left is so like Cortez and Omar and
that whole new crew in the democratic socialists who are only holding onto the
word democratic for another year or two and then they'll just be social.
This,
I think they've got all the energy they've got.
They feel like they have the young people.
They certainly have the woke media.
And what's happening is,
and this is why I'm actually hopeful,
uh,
because you said you were an optimist.
I always say I'm a world weary optimist.
It's like I believe that.
Yeah,
they can keep doing that and they will implode on itself.
You're going to have to take down Bernie one day.
He's an old white man.
You'll,
you'll,
you'll destroy each other.
But what I think mostly will happen is the d decent liberals like yourself.
We'll just more and more realize that there is something happening center,
right?
Right now that is not racist,
that is based on freedom and liberty and individual rights and is respectful of
differences.
And there's some pro choice people there and some prolife people and some gay
people and straight people.
And I think that's where the,
the few,
I think that if America will continue as a great nation and a free nation,
that's the future of it.
The other thing,
they're not going to stop.
They can't stop.
They've had so many chances to stop Trump president.
Yeah.
That seems like it would have been a reason to reflect.
No,
this is the crazy thing is the conversation with my friend who might not any
feed my friend anymore.
He said,
well,
he's not gonna win.
I'm like,
yeah,
I hear this all the time from people.
How can you say that
he won?
You are saying to me the exact same thing that you said in 2016 that you said
was impossible.
Your saying it's impossible.
I'm get like,
how are you saying this?
How cognitive dissonance,
I don't understand.
I don't understand that.
That's where I'm at.
That's where I just,
I'm like,
okay,
bye,
bye.
I try to be,
I listened,
but there are certain things where I'm,
I'm like,
I don't understand how you can think.
That's a logical thought to have.
There's no chance.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
The thing that just happened,
the thing that just happened that you said was impossible and he said,
well,
you have to understand bridges.
Then when you say that to people,
you are basically shitting on all of their hope.
And I'm like,
well,
okay,
so now it's my responsibility to take care of everyone else in the world's
feelings.
And this is the new thing where you're supposed to just manage everyone in the
world's.
One of the first things I learned in Rehab when I was 19 is that it's none of my
business how anyone feels about me.
Yeah.
And now it's like apparently I have to make sure everyone around me is okay.
And
because then you can never think about yourself.
And that's really what they don't want.
It's a,
it's interesting.
I agree.
That's what they really want.
They don't want you to be able to think about what you really think.
So they keep you focused on everybody else all the time.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
I think we're living in,
I'm excited.
I like,
most people are like,
oh,
they just times that we live.
I love it.
I think it's exciting and I think it's dangerous and terrifying as well.
And there are days,
you know,
when I was getting these emails about how people self sensor it was,
I was in a dark place and my cousin came over Maggie and she said,
we need to get you the f out of this like whole year in because it was hundreds
of hundreds of emails.
But the language people are using.
Thank you for giving me permission to speak freely.
Thank you for allowing me to,
I'm s I F I don't know if this will end up anywhere,
but it just feels so good to get that out.
And these,
they assume they're in these things and people saying,
you know,
the,
some of the people on the left trolled man had it all.
They were like these intentionally racist things.
But most of the emails I got were very thoughtful and very,
um,
you know,
places there's people are,
well it's not people that are sticking out far right positions,
I think is what you're saying.
People that are just saying maybe I'm for low taxes or something and they were
afraid to say it because you're getting oh,
your concerned.
Yeah.
And also just the way that it's infecting policy,
like you say you'd like we've used has been set on here and people say that the
politics are downstream of culture.
So just the way that,
uh,
one man was saying,
well,
it's,
um,
we really are afraid to criticize the code of certain hires because it could end
you up in HR.
And so,
and he's like,
and this is code that is kind of important.
These are the soft of affects of,
you know,
on the marketplace.
And then the world of ideas that we can't see that were,
and you can really only see if you ask for people to be truly honest and
fearless or if people start speaking up,
but you're not going to see that.
Um,
because it's so subtle.
It's so insidious.
That's the thing about self censorship.
It's so it starts,
you know,
it starts in the mind and then,
and once you start doing it,
you just keep going.
It's almost impossible to remember that original person
and it's easier to,
for instance,
you can't burn a buck if you get it banned before it's even published.
I mean these are things that I deeply concerned me there more concerning.
I feel like there's a lot of corruption and stuff that that we have to take aim
at.
You know,
I feel like it's our job as citizens and this is really my,
my big,
where I stand now is kind of with you I guess in the middle and saying like the
center must hold.
We,
I had abandoned my job as a citizen of looking critically at everybody and the
fact that somebody like myself or you who might be looking critically at things
on the right and critically on things on the right that's controversial is,
is very bad news for democracy because that is our job as citizens not to be
loyal to some party.
It's to be critical of our leaders and all the people who want to leaders,
not
just like on some team.
This isn't like the red sox and the Yankees.
They shouldn't automatically vote for whoever Katy Perry like,
I mean Taylor swift silence is definitely
is definitely we are going to do this many times more.
I have no doubt.
I,
I'm glad we finally did.
We need people like you out there doing this stuff.
We need straight,
white,
heterosexual,
cisgender chicks.
I mean,
that's basically what you are.
I just think people need to know they're not alone.
I think a lot of people,
what I've realized from the self censorship bed,
people think they're alone.
They're not alone.
If you're a reasonable person out there and you're feeling like you're going
crazy,
you're not alone and there's,
you know,
reach out to you,
email me,
whatever.
If you feel,
if you're in the dark place,
um,
yeah.
And find,
find others who you can speak freely with and have conversations with because I
think that is important.
That's why I'm doing stand up again and we got to go.
We'll do a gig together.
Yeah.
They're together because that's the point of it is just messing around with the
crowd.
We get in that room and we just got,
that would be so fun.
It's like I want people to look around the room and be like,
yeah,
guess what?
That guy likes Trump.
You like Bernie.
It's okay.
We're not killing each other now we're going to do that.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Well,
you guys can follow Bridget on Twitter.
It's at Bridget fed Z,
although you will be talking to cousin back,
but she's,
she's a lovely woman.
She's amazing.
Amazing.
We love you.
Maggie.